hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter three
of on freedom of choice Anselm of
Canterbury is going to bring in a new
set of considerations in the dialogue
between teacher and student trying to
determine what exactly freedom of choice
is and what its purposes are and how to
understand it best so we're beginning
here from the realization that he's
brought his students through that free
choice Libertas arbitrary is for
uprightness of will rectitude oval and
POTUS in in Latin and it has a certain
purpose or teleology a directedness so
free choice freedom Libertas is not
simply being able to do what anything
whatsoever that would actually fit more
into potestas of which later on we find
out that Libertas freedom is is a
species of that genus so Anselm is going
to add here something he says there
would be doubts still dubium if
something else was not added some other
consideration was not going into and
here we're talking about the exploring
this teleology of why it is that we not
only have a
we'll of Volant us and we not only have
the possibility of rightness of will
rectitude o Volant on tests but why we
have this this power or capacity this
potestas of maintaining rightness of
will so Ansem asks the question in what
manner quomodo in in latin in what way
in what what mode we might even say more
close to the to the cognate did Adam and
the fallen angel have it now why is he
worried about Adam and the fallen angel
they provide a sort of test case for us
we can think about our own lives and how
murky they are the choices that we make
and all the different motivations we
might have in the weighing of
consequences and prioritizations but if
we think about you know the initial
choices made by this you know earliest
human being Adam and the going even
further back a being who doesn't even
you know have a body to weigh him down
or anything like that the fallen angel
who of course they put in brackets is
Satan we can get a better handle on why
this ability was provided not just to
them but to rational beings in general
which for an some include God human
beings and the Angels whether you know
good or bad right
so he lays out a set of four
possibilities and he says to the student
think about these was freedom of choice
given to Adam in the fallen angel for
these purposes which you know which of
it wasn't was it given to them in order
to acquire uprightness of will without
anyone giving it since they did not yet
have it so were they created in such a
way where they you
you can think of them as like computers
with having slots that you can fit cards
into you know did they have a slot for
uprightness of will and they could go
out and find the right you know hardware
and then stick it in there is that is
that the case that's possibility number
one that they could acquire rectitude of
will without anyone giving it because
they didn't yet have it or is it in
order to receive the uprightness of will
they did not yet have if it were given
them to have so some other agency would
give it to them and then they would be
able to receive it and be able to keep
it or here's a third possibility were
they given the uprightness of will like
something that is you know like a
default again let's use hardware and
software this time let's think about
software your initial settings right
your initial settings everything is
totally clean and then you you know play
around with your software for a while
and you get some some you know problems
with it some bugs some malware and then
you just as fine will just revert back
to factory settings and begin again
right we'll do a wipe well you know
that's that's kind of like what Anselm
was talking about here in order to be
able to desert or you know give give up
uprightness of will and then recover it
back on their own themselves after they
deserted it or here's the fourth
possibility were they given up rightness
of will so that they could always act to
keep the uprightness of will that they
had received and so the student is going
to go through each of these
possibilities and say whether they
really make sense or not so the first
possibility being given the uprightness
of will without anyone's giving it since
they did not yet have it the student
says I don't think they had freedom in
order to acquire uprightness without
anyone's giving it because they were not
able to have anything which they did not
receive so you know whatever it is that
they started out with they got it from
somewhere else they didn't
here it on their own so you know
presumably this would apply not just to
Adam and the fallen angel but also to
ourselves as well he gives a little bit
more attention to possibility number two
he says we must not believe they were
created without upright wills so we must
not say that they had freedom in order
to receive from a giver the gift of the
uprightness that they did not have in
order that they might have it yet we
must not deny that they had the freedom
to receive the same uprightness again if
they deserted it and it would return to
them by the one who originally gave it
and so an Psalm that has the teacher say
listen you're getting a little bit off
topic here it's an interesting point
that once a being has lost that
rightness of will it can be given back
to them again if they can indeed receive
it which he he thinks is the case for
human beings but not for the Fallen
Angels that's discussed in a later trees
the fall of the devil so this one is
being rejected as well but there's an
interesting corollary being spelled out
there
the third one he says it's not true that
they had freedom in order to desert this
uprightness that's a stupid thing to do
to desert this uprightness of will is to
sin and to sin is the freedom or the
ability to sin is neither freedom nor a
part of freedom why not because it's the
ability to damage one's self it's the
ability to do what is you know not
appropriate or not befitting and what is
not it you know helpful or expedient for
oneself what what is bad for oneself but
it says nor looking at the second part
of this nor did they receive freedom in
order to recover by their own efforts
the uprightness that they had deserted
this uprightness was given to the end
that it never be deserted and a little
bit later in the treatise and someone's
going to say listen once you've
abandoned operate nosov will you
can app by virtue of your own willing
get it back somebody else has to give it
back to you
somebody has to restore your condition
and then you can you can keep it so the
alter the only other alternative here
then is the fourth that we should we
were given an ant atom and and you know
the angels were given this this a you
know freedom of will and the uprightness
that goes along with it in order to keep
the uprightness of will that they had
received always in every case not not as
something to you know put aside for a
little while and come back to something
that should be the top priority in any
decision-making
you know procedure or opportunity what
he's saying here in effect is that
uprightness of will was given so that
they could value it as the thing that's
most worth keeping the thing that's most
worth pursuing as an end and that would
allow them to continue on doing that in
the case of both adam and the fallen
angel they didn't do that and they
suffered certain consequences which led
to them not being able to you know have
that that anymore which meant that they
had in fact not completely effaced their
freedom of choice but they had rendered
their freedom of choice in some respects
in operable so long as they don't get
that rectitude of will back in the case
of the fallen angel never gets it back
so in effect he nullified the freedom of
choice that he was given in the case of
adam you know whatever the condition
happens to be you know if we think that
Adam was was you know redeemed in some
way then presumably so how would this
affect us from an Anselm Ian perspective
well we would have been given and if we
get receive it back
the you know rightness or rectitude of
will in order to always keep it that is
the point of it and that is what allows
us to have an exercise free choice
Libertas arbitrary in its full scope
from an insomnia
you